there are so many
small companies who've been devastated
this year we have not seen a sustained
attack
on mom and pop shops uh like we've seen
in 2020
who are innovators and making something
happen
and when you're just like one dude who's
producing a product they're a sponsor of
mine i'm happy
to first of all it's funny that i'm
pitching underwear but haha pitching but
it's also
something i enjoy she said small
business yeah yeah it's microscopic like
a thimble
so this isn't a sponsor of mine but this
is a good segue
so this is the russians we celebrate new
year's november
we have died murals he comes down puts a
present under your pillow
so this is a company called jl lawson
he's a fan of yours he's a metal worker
and he said can i give you something to
give to lex
i have one of his worry coins i'll tell
you what it is he's not a sponsor this
is not i'm not getting paid for this
so what a worry coin is i carry around
in my butt if you have raw denim it's
great because it brings you fades
so you carry it around with you all the
time it says worrying
it's like paying a debt you don't oh
right and i carry this around
and now it's been like a year next time
you're worrying and this is a good
advice if you don't have a word coin
go think about 10 years ago yes and what
you were worried about then
and then think about did any of those
things pan out and some of them did
but you were able to handle it and
that's a good way to
maintain perspective so jl lawson's the
company he sent me this present i said
let me give it to lex on air
so enjoy should i also open it
yeah jl lawson and co
two lex from anthony yeah and i said
make something mathematical for lex i
don't even know what's in there
you don't know what's in there no when
it got through was tsa
it could be a bomb it could be just like
this episode
make sure you unwrap it close to mike
because it drives you for crazy
that's really the best part
me or is this what unboxing video looks
like
i think so this conversation's going to
be a big hit
on the internet with the unboxing
community
i need to have an exciting look on my
face to make sure
the reaction video it should be an
unboxing and a reaction video
lex screaming reacts it's another box
it's just a series of boxes lex
big fan since hearing you on roger
months ago
most of your guests are over my head but
still enjoyable
ah like this episode michael was kind
enough to want to share
my work with you keep doing what you do
anthony
lawson thanks anthony
there's a lot in there what is in there
give me some i'll open some okay all
right
by the way show it to the camera and
then make sure you look excited
or not or disappointed no this is cool
this is a worry coin like i was showing
you
oh so you hold it in your hand and when
you can do this with your thumb if
people are have anxiety or whatever oh
there's a lot of cool stuff in here
fibonacci coin
oh see yeah that's the math stuff that's
really awesome
this is really cool wait you got a big
one line there too
that's what she said
i'm telling you last time you offended
me saying i don't have humor
so i
uh the spin tray micro brass and copper
bronze by the way the packaging is epic
i think that's his top he makes tops
cool yeah you spin it in there
and it's the two different uh bronze and
copper
i think he's the only one who makes
these machined tops
and then he's sitting here i guess yeah
but you could spin him in that
stack that section got it cool
you